all right thank you for having me um so
my name is dylan gardner and today i
want to talk to you about why i think
auc is worthless and some of the lessons
that i've learned in making a transition
from academia to working in business and
data science
and so to start i want to talk a little
bit about my background because these
are my biases where i come from i'm
going to share a lot of opinions with
you some of my you might think are
incorrect so this is where i'm coming
from so my background is in physics i
have a phd in experimental physics from
mit
i've been working as a data scientist
for seven years and i've worked in a
number of different fields worked in
electricity markets programmatic
advertising ag tech fintech and i've
worked in companies as small as four
people and upwards of about 800 people
i've held roles sort of as an individual
contributor
and also as a manager and i think one of
the most important things for this talk
is i've also had the experience of being
laid off and uh you know i think that's
a very rude uh and harsh awakening to
some of the realities of doing work in
in business um and it's definitely
informed a lot about how i think about
these things
so to motivate this i want to have a
little bit of a preamble and talk about
job descriptions and so if you look at a
job posting such as this one this is
from enigma which is a really great
company it happens to be the company
that i currently work at
and we're hiring so if you're interested
take a look here's a segment of the job
description
and what you'll see is there's a number
of
i don't know if not exactly requirements
but things that you were looking for
that i would say lean very technical
um and then in addition there's some
other requirements uh this one i'll
highlight that is somehow you know
something other than the real technical
skills and so here we're talking about
you know we're looking for people who
approach data as an artifact of the real
world and develop repeatable strategies
for validating results against ground
truth
and so there's something where we're
really trying to emphasize the fact that
this is a real world problem this isn't
sort of toy problems
here's another job description this is
for apollo agriculture it's a really
great company it's the company i used to
work for
i'd highly recommend you check them out
they're also hiring
and here we have a lot of different uh
you know
things that are being looked for and two
of them that i want to highlight here
are you know are comfortable explaining
complex solutions to non-data science
peers across multiple continents and
cultures
and the second one is you know having
product management skills to maximize
impact of data science work so we're
sort of emphasizing these communication
skills and really getting the impact out
of the work
and just in case you think that i'm
cherry-picking these examples of the
companies from which i worked here's
another company you may have heard of
them i'll let you make your own decision
about whether or not it's a great
company
and there are similarly these
non-technical things where we're looking
for experience articulating and
translating business equations and using
statistical techniques to arrive at an
answer using available data
and the second one which really is
probably two
but the one i want to emphasize is
effective written and verbal
communication skills
then if we contrast that to the syllabus
that we may have so this is the you know
intro to machine learning course from
mit it's the first class that i took in
machine learning and everything is
purely technical
this is also true if you look at sort of
data science boot camps there tends to
be a very strong technical uh emphasis
in the syllabus
and also if you look in sort of the
literature so you're learning from books
and things there's this very strong
technical emphasis and very little
emphasis on these other skills that we
know the company wants
and so what i'd say is there's a there's
a little bit of a mismatch here and what
companies want is in part driven by the
fact that there are many people and
different people are looking for
different things
so you have a data scientist who's
involved with the hiring process and
they might be looking for what we can
say are these are the you know sort of
standard three pillars of data science
we're talking about you know machine
learning and programming statistics and
math and domain expertise
but on top of that there's also sort of
a business persona there's business
people involved and they're looking for
things that are slightly different so
they are really emphasizing the nature
of you know real world data we're not
working with toy problems but something
that's you know fundamentally
rooted in reality a strong emphasis on
communication
and here you know it's not like the
ability to give a really nice talk at a
friend's wedding it's about how do you
communicate across the business of how
can you make sense of the data science
work that you're doing
and the third thing is a little bit more
like product management which is saying
you know how do you really take what
you've done as a data scientist
and how do we get value out of our data
hard data science work
and so i you know to me i think there's
there's a mismatch here when we talk
about uh what we think of and by we i
mean all of us as data scientists what
we think leads to success is maybe
something like this where it's like an
80 20 mix of these technical skills with
other skills and in reality i think what
leads to success is more like 50 50.
and so this mismatch is something that
i've really noticed in my career and
something that i want to try and
help um
help us as data scientists get better uh
at understanding this and what success
might look like
i think it's also helpful to sort of
think about why is there this mismatch
um and so
these are my opinions from thinking
about this and i think you know one of
the major reasons is that classes
programs about data science about
machine learning tend to be taught by
academics
and as an academic you have another job
and that other job is doing research
that is looking to try and expand what
is possible in data science and in
machine learning so typically
somebody who's teaching a data science
class might also be spending their time
working on doing something like you know
improving the error rate in imagenet
which is a way that we're using to say
here's a new technique and this
technique is moving our field forward
but that looks really different from
what happens in a business setting
i also think that
we are just as general as as data
scientists we're more comfortable with
assessing technical skills and so when
it comes time to doing job interviews
we typically will build a panel uh
around the technical side because that's
something we're comfortable with as data
scientists
i also think we're more comfortable
teaching technical skills and so
the way in which we tend to think about
how can we improve as data scientists
there's this strong emphasis on
technical because our mentors are
comfortable if you are working as a
mentor if i'm working as a mentor it's
easier for me to focus on the technical
and then the third reason or the fourth
reason
is i think that as data scientists
sometimes we disdain some of the
business side so this one okay i will
admit i'm maybe not quite as certain
about but i think this can be a pattern
that can happen
so with this in mind i want to do a
little bit of a trip to business school
and the way i want to do that is i want
to start talking about scoring functions
when we do our work as data scientists
it's it's really helpful to make a clear
distinction between loss functions and
scoring functions when i talk about loss
functions what we're talking about is
what the ml algorithm is trying to
minimize
the scoring function is more in line
with what the business is trying to
minimize so you might also think about
this as a cost function
or a utility function
which gives maybe you're maximizing it
so a loss function will need to have
really nice mathematical properties
maybe it needs to be differentiable
these are the kinds of things that
you're ultimately doing gradient descent
you're doing back prop on in order to
minimize and a scoring function can be
very very arbitrary
so as examples if we think about loss
versus scoring functions
in our loss function we might have
something like the root mean squared
error we might be talking about cross
entropy we're thinking about things like
regularization
and in our scoring functions we're
thinking about things like accuracy f1
score
uh auc
auc
okay so these these loss functions when
we're doing this as data scientists what
happens is there's there's these two
different kind of processes that happen
for the loss function this is where the
internals of our algorithm is trying to
do the optimization and we're trying to
do some kind of you know gradient
descent
type of optimization
whereas when we're doing the scoring
functions what we're talking about is
the model selections this is like hyper
parameter tuning we're doing things like
grid search in order to figure out which
of all of these candidate models that we
can build are going to do the best
according to the scoring functions we
care about
and in reality though it's not just a
single scoring function there's there's
more complex way we can think about it
in terms of businesses
and so for a business they don't really
care about accuracy f1 score or auc
except as a proxy for the things that
they really care about which are things
like profit your loss ratio maybe things
like your model complexity
explainability you have worked in the
past in an organization where we were
heavily regulated and so we needed to
work with regulators to convince them
that this model was actually going to
work and so in that case we needed to be
very explicit and and penalize ourselves
if we were using a complex model because
that was harder to get through the
regulatory
environment that we were operating in
and so there's this sense of business
optimization as well
and the thing that i would argue though
is that we're better off if we're
working in business as data scientists
to not think about these academic
scoring functions but instead when we're
doing our model selection we should be
thinking about these business scoring
functions as well and so we want to as
early as possible start taking these
kinds of considerations into account
when we're doing our work as data
scientists
okay so
you know if we think about like how
products are discussed if we're working
as data scientists an often thing that
happens is something like this where
there's a business person who's thinking
about you know profit loss ratio model
complexity explainability and the data
scientist is talking about accuracy f1
score and auc and when you're in this
situation this is a recipe for failure
okay this is the kind of thing that'll
lead you to getting laid off
or your team laid off or your business
will fail
so an alternative thing might look like
this where now the business people are
talking about things like accuracy f1
score and auc and when you're in this
case like this works like this this can
be successful and this can lead to you
know praise promotion pay raises all the
great things that we want when we're
working in a company
but the thing that happens here is this
is most of that's going to go to the
business person because they're the
people who did all of the work to try
and take that business consideration and
then map it into something that we can
use our tools for as data scientists
so a better way to do this is if as a
data scientist you and
your team and our team start using the
languages of business and this will also
be successful and in this case
the preferential praises promotions pay
raises will go to us as data scientists
because we're doing all of that hard
work to figure out how can we map
our clever data science work into the
things that the business cares about
okay so how do we get there
and so i want to spend a little bit of
an aside talking about roc curves in auc
just to make sure we're all on the same
page
and so an roc
curve the way we think about this is
it's a trade-off between the false
positive rates and the true positive
rates and so the true positive rate is
the fraction of positives that we're
correctly classifying as positive
and the false positive rate is the
fraction of negatives that we are
classifying as positive
and in these diagrams we say this
diagonal is just random so if we're just
you have a random number generator your
model will live on this diagram
on the diagonal of this diagram
and if we're better than random we're
going to live
um in the top left if we're worse than
random we'll live on the bottom right
but in reality you can't be worse than
random because you just multiply by
negative one and then you're better than
random
so a model might live on your diagram
and it looks something like this and
what this is expressing is the way in
which your model has gotten to the point
where we can have different trade-offs
between true positives and false
positives
and if we start with a hundred percent
rejection so we're saying everything is
we're calling everything false then we
start down in this bottom left and we
end up if we move all the way to
accepting everybody we end up in the top
right and the model is the trace of of
the curve of what's possible
or the model line yeah
and the auc then is just the area in
this squiggle
and so this will go from 0.5 if you have
a completely random model and one if you
have a perfect model
okay so
now i want to talk through an example of
how this would look in practice and so
the example i want to talk about is loan
applications
so
business people come up and they say hey
give me a model that determines if an
applicant for a loan should be approved
or should be denied
and then we as data scientists say great
i'll build a classifier that learns to
predict who will repay a loan
um and yeah so for this like we'll make
the simplifying assumption that
everything is paid either as a lump sum
um so it's 100 repayment or you don't
pay at all and it's 100 default just
make things easy for us okay so now we
go off we do our work and we're like all
right we have success we have a model
this is wonderful
but you know how do we know this model
is any good
and how do we know that even if it is
good if it's better than the cost that
it takes to use this model
and how do we know
that this model is better than no model
at all
you know so however we answer these
kinds of questions i think is is the
critical part
and then if we have two models you know
i have two different choices
which which of these models are better
if you're thinking about something like
auc then you're like well obviously the
model with higher auc
but this is really a an
unuseful way of thinking about it if
you're working in a business environment
what we really care about is which
trade-off between the true positive
rates and the false positive rates will
give us better options as a business
so to motivate how we're going to make
that decision we'll start by thinking
about our confusion matrix and what i
want to do is go through and figure out
what is the value in each of these
squares of our confusion matrix and just
to say what is the business going to
gain or lose for each of these four
possible outcomes
and that's literally what we need to do
like we need to fill these things in and
so how do we go about doing this well
it's not necessarily your job by
yourself it's not our jobs as data
scientists to know these answers we need
to go talk to the business and figure
this out so we need to go talk to the
cfo talk to the ceo talk to the product
manager and try and figure these sorts
of things out
in the case of this loan example you
could say well look if somebody applies
for a loan our model says they should
get a loan
what happens well we get the price that
we're going to charge them but we also
have to add in the cost of the goods and
services that we're giving them we have
to add in the interest that we need to
pay during that time period and we have
to add in the cost that we paid to
acquire this customer so these would be
things like your marketing costs it
would also include like application
costs for them to to go through your
process
including your model
what happens on the other hand if our
model says that this person is a is a
good credit risk we should give them a
loan and they don't repay
we have all of the same costs of goods
and services interest and the customer
acquisition costs but we don't get the
price that we're charging they didn't
repay
in the case that our model says no then
the impact on the business is actually
the same it's just the customer
acquisition cost it doesn't matter
whether they would have repaid or they
wouldn't have repaid and in fact we
probably won't ever even know which
would have been the case
okay so then you say wait is this right
and i think this is an important point
is that like you know it's maybe like
you know we don't really know for sure
some of these things might change things
like your marketing costs customer
requisition costs like we don't really
know and there are other terms that you
might consider adding in and so
in the past for example i was working
for a company that was involved with
this and we realized that we had a
additional value that we wanted to
account for
in that we preferentially wanted to give
out loans because that's how our models
got better over time if we didn't give
out the loan we don't get the data back
in order to figure out how do we improve
so we wanted to add in some kind of
explicit representation of that which we
had is like a value of learning
so there's some some uncertainty here
um and in the end you might end up with
like filling these numbers in and it
might look something like this
these numbers are made up they are just
completely random because they made the
rest of the examples look a little
easier
all right and now what we want to try
and do is take advantage of these
numbers and then we can calculate the
utility for each point in this true
positive false positive space
to help us understand which of these
different trade-offs are better
and so this is where i would say okay
now we're going to do our little algebra
train crank and try and calculate the
expected utility in this true positive
false positive space and to do this
we'll start by saying okay we need to
define these terms we'll say the
prevalence is the probability that a
given example is positive which we'll
say is the total number of positive
cases in our example divided by the
total number of cases
and the negatives which is something
that i just made up right now
is the probability that an example is
negative so it's 1 minus the prevalence
and if we take that then we can
explicitly write down the expected
utility for any one applicant for any
point in this true positive false
positive space
and
okay this is how it works
if you don't believe my algebra happy to
talk to you about it afterwards
and that's that's now where we are uh so
now we have this idea of how we can
figure out uh in this space where
everything is and so to start with we
can say look like what happens if we
just reject everybody and so if we plug
that through and uh we're operating in a
situation where the prevalence is 0.5
which is say half of people repay half
of them do not
then each applicant that we're rejecting
is worth minus 10 which is to say we're
paying minus 10 in the customer
acquisition cost
for everybody who applies and then we
just reject them so probably not a very
good business model um
and then we can say okay well what
happens if we accept everybody and so if
we accept everybody we can look in this
formula plug in these numbers and we end
up at minus -26 units so an even worse
business model
and so if you're in this situation your
default choice
if you don't have a model is just to
reject everybody
obviously we want to do better than that
okay so um let's go back to our little
algebra crank and one of the things that
we can do is for a given amount of
utility if we keep that as a constant we
can see that in this true positive false
positive space for a constant value of
utility there's this linear relationship
and so we can solve for this and we can
say that the slope is independent of the
utility
and the intercept matters on the utility
sorry yeah
independent of the expected utility only
the intercept matters on the expected
utility and
okay so now here what we can do is we
can draw a line and so this is the same
utility as rejecting everybody
what this line means is i can be
completely indifferent anywhere on this
line and i will have the exact same
result in terms of the impact on the
business as if i just rejected everybody
this is all the same
so that's the point okay so this is the
the first major thing and i think this
is like maybe a little bit
counterintuitive anywhere on this line
is worth exactly the same
similarly we can say okay what happens
if we were accepting everybody everybody
everywhere on this line is going to be
worth exactly the same as rejecting
everybody
and we'll see that
in general we can write a series of
lines on here with increasing utility as
we move up into the left so each one of
these lines as a business we are
completely indifferent where we live on
but we want to be climbing up this slope
to higher and higher utility which goes
up and to the left
okay now if i
say that like there are good
macroeconomic things in happening and so
people are more likely to repay their
loan the economy is doing better and so
the prevalence goes up to 0.6 from 0.5
so nothing changed in our business
just everything is external to us
suddenly that means our slope changes
and the thing that is really important
to notice is once this happens the best
option by default becomes accept
everybody and so this change in slope
matters a lot and it all happens
relative to zero
so in this case the slope is now less
than one and whenever that happens that
means your default choice should be to
accept everybody
okay so the slope is the thing that
really matters and so this is what i'm
saying where the slope changes so on the
on the left the slope is left less than
one where our default choice is to
accept everybody on the right it's
greater than one so our default choice
is to reject everybody
and that means that when we're doing our
model this helps us understand ahead of
time where we're going to get the most
value out of our model in the in the
first case when we're in the top left we
can have a model with a very small auc
but we can still get value out of it as
a business in the other case we really
want to be on the bottom
we want to be yeah here and we can still
get value so it can still be a small auc
but we're going to start doing a lot
better than our default choice as a
business
okay so then how does this work if we
are in
if we have a model
so once we have a model now we're doing
a constrained optimization problem and
so this is the the problem of
you can do think of this as lagrange
multipliers and what happens is the
optimal point with a model is going to
be at the tangent of these lines and so
this is a property of lagrange
multipliers and the way we can
intuitively think about this is we're
trying to climb up as high as we can get
but we have to live on this curve and
that highest point that we can possibly
get to on a curve is when we start
walking completely parallel to to the
slope and so that's where the optimal
point is going to be once we have a
model
okay so the optimal choice is going to
either be on a tangent line of our model
or it will be that our model ends up not
being very valuable and it will be
either a hundred percent reject or a
hundred percent uh deny
the other thing that's interesting about
thinking about this math is that it
tells us already something that i think
a lot of people intuitively think about
when they're dealing with an roc curve
to think about their model is that they
often think about their their threshold
is typically going to be in an area
where there's a lot of curvature to your
roc curve and this is the mathematical
underpinning of why that's the case it's
saying that there are many many
different slopes in an area of high
curvature that are likely to be the
optimal point so even if you're slightly
wrong in terms of estimating the the
utility matrix
you're still probably going to want to
live in this area of high curvature
okay so i want to show you a different
case this is now if the slopes change
because the prevalence changes now a
model with the same oh
that's not what i did sorry if i flip my
model and now my model is the same auc
but in the other side of the space this
model doesn't do anything for us because
we're still always below the the curve
that is the same as rejecting everybody
so even though this model has the exact
same auc as the previous model it
doesn't help us we're still better off
as a business to just reject everyone
which you know
kind of unfortunate
okay
so
what i've sort of seen here then is that
it's really the slope is the thing that
matters the most when we do this math
and so
as a physicist one of the things that i
always learned is you know you look at
an equation like this and we try and
sort of look at extremes of what happens
how do we try and make sense of this
and so when we look at this like one of
the things to think about then is you
know what happens when the slope gets
really really big
that happens when means we can need a
high precision model meaning that it's
going to be hard to beat
just reject everybody and so i can look
at this slope and say what are the
things that would make this true and so
that's going to say if for example the
cost of a false positive goes really
really high then that means that we're
probably just going to be in a position
where our default choice will be reject
everybody and so we can get value by
having this
very high precision model with maybe a
very low acceptance rate
conversely when the slope is very small
that means we need to have a high recall
model it's going to be hard to
beat just accept everybody
and so that would be for example if like
the true positive is very very high
then that's going to change where we
need to be focusing
the other thing that's really
interesting to point out is that
all of these terms come in in pairs and
they're subtracted and that means that
if there's any term that we think about
the utility of this that shows up in
every single term in our matrix then
it's not going to impact our slope at
all and that means that it won't impact
our optimal decision so this is actually
the mathematical representation of like
the sunk cost fallacy
which is to say you know once you've
already paid that money it doesn't
really matter you shouldn't make any
decisions after it uh after the fact
so if we look in our in our the way in
which we were defining this before
you'll see that this customer
acquisition cost shows up in every term
and so what that means is when we're
making a decision
for how we want to set our thresholds
then we actually don't need to consider
customer acquisition cost
and the reason for that is because
you've already paid that that money's
already been spent as a business by the
time that application gets to the data
science model um so it doesn't matter
so this is something that maybe you
already know um you know you you
remember your high school economics uh i
certainly forgot it you run through this
problem and then and then you sort of
see the value of of doing this kind of
effort um to to to know that you're
making these decisions intelligently
okay so summary um when we talk about
the utility and rc curves what happens
is you get the curves of constant
utility are going to be straight lines
the slope is the thing that determines
the behavior in the absence of the model
and also the slope determines what
region of the roc space we want to try
and live in as modelers
the optimal points are typically going
to be tangents and so that's why we need
to be focusing on the areas of large
curvature
and then if the model results are bad uh
this can happen even though you have
you know real
ability in your model there's a positive
auc
then it still isn't working and so maybe
you need to change the business
so maybe you need to think about
reducing your customer acquisition cost
think about changing your price things
along these lines
one of the things that
you know i always think about too when
dealing with a model is it's really
helpful to figure out when is this
breakdown so this is a toy model that i
made
and it doesn't capture everything it's
very helpful but it doesn't capture
everything so here are some of the ways
it can break down
one thing that this doesn't include is
any sort of feedback loops so in reality
if you start changing your acceptance
rate as a business then you're going to
change who's going to be applying
and so there's that kind of feedback
loop that can happen
the other thing that you can do is you
can have multiple thresholds so you
don't necessarily have to just have like
accept uh or or deny you can also have a
reject accept or have like a human
review in the middle
um you could also have variable loan
terms depending on the risk so you you
know you don't necessarily have to just
have a constant price but you can change
change the price
also this is modeled as like an
unending stream of applicants where you
just are you know saying accept or deny
on an unending stream and in reality you
might have capital constraints so
instead of just trying to optimize on a
per applicant you need to consider how
much money can i possibly lend out as a
business
and then
the other thing is it's not always super
simple to figure out what the business
is trying to optimize and so you know
this is sort of a per customer
optimization but you might be thinking
about things like lifetime customer
value
things like this and sometimes it's so
hard that if you're talking to you know
the business side and people can't give
you a straight answer then maybe there's
also a bigger problem with the business
okay so these are my conclusions and
recommendations so i'd say you know it's
really helpful to try and get a little
bit of an understanding of the business
logic i think a lot of the ways in which
the business
is thought through is basically algebra
whereas all of the machine learning
these data science skills are
essentially calculus and so i'd say that
if if we can learn how to do back prop
we can learn uh you know svm then we can
take the time to learn a little bit of
business the it's really not that
complicated
i would also say that we should do the
effort to try and learn these business
outcomes early doing it earlier as part
of our model development will lead to
better outcomes in the end
and finally what i say is that as data
scientists we need to be really talking
with people on the business side of the
company we are not responsible for doing
all these things by ourselves we don't
work in a vacuum we need to be very
collaborative and we also need to make
sure that when we build a model like
this people are on board that this is
the correct way to think about the
business
okay
so that's my opinion on auc so if there
are any questions comments or
disagreements happy to hear them
thank you very much
hi um
thanks for the
talk
um
my question
was maybe more towards the beginning of
your
talk um when you were talking about you
know when how we
kind of
data scientists become data scientists
and how they are recruited
and so what would you advise on the more
like on the interview inside of of of
the question given that in order to
assess someone's um
business skills is sometimes quite hard
to actually set the context within a
very time to constraint like interview i
guess setting it's much easier to us as
technical skills than
yeah it's a really good question so one
of the things that
uh we do in my current company that i
think is very helpful is we actually
have product be involved in the
interview process with data scientists
and so
we've built together like a case study
that is more
business centric to try and get a sense
of how does somebody think about this
i was thinking one of the other aspects
of it that
i think a lot of companies do this i've
seen this in companies i've worked for
is there's also the sense with on the
technical skills that you really only
need to kind of test technical skills to
the point of capabilities because it's
often easier to teach
the gaps that somebody might have so as
long as you can sort of convince
yourself that somebody has
you know sufficient ability to learn
those technical skills that they might
be missing it's easier for for us as
data scientists to teach those skills up
and and instead prioritize trying to
find people who have
interest you know abilities backgrounds
whatever in some of these other skills
as well
uh thanks for the talk i really
appreciate it and uh yeah especially the
interaction on on business aspects is is
very important i agree especially as you
climb up the ladders and
you're less cushioned by others
yeah so my only question is quite
technical uh so your focus here was on
uh true positive rates and false
positive rates my understanding correct
you may find it correct but
uh
i think that's that's that graph is
useful if you're dealing with a balance
set in which you're expecting a 50 50
split and otherwise uh one wants to
focus on precision versus recall
um yeah i remember an article like uh
nailing that at that point so what's
your opinion about that yeah so so
actually maybe talk through this
slightly too quickly but this is this is
kind of what happens here like the
difference between these two graphs is a
change the unit economics are the same
but the but the split between positives
and negative changes so on on the right
if i remember the numbers correctly this
is 50 50 on the on the right and on the
left it's it's 60 40. and that's what
changed the the
the slopes because this that does show
up in the in the slope equation uh
here
so this is you know this is the term
these like r and rp
are related to the prevalence uh
yeah of course the total falls out so
this is the same thing as the total
number of negatives divided by the total
number of positives so it shows up in
the slope and that's exactly the the
intuition that i think you can build as
you're sort of saying is
if you are in a very imbalanced way
then in some sense if you're extremely
imbalanced then the unit economics
matter less than the imbalance
and so you know as long as your terms
are sort of roughly the same order of
magnitude but your your your balance is
orders of magnitude difference then that
dominates your slope term and that will
do exactly as i was sort of saying and
trying to try and explain in in this
summary slide here where it's saying
like yeah i think this is the point
you're making right when the slopes are
really really small you need to have a
high recall model and the slope's really
really big you need to have a high
precision model
okay yeah that sounds about right so
you're giving like a utility function as
opposed to the f1 score that all of us
use on precision recall exactly and so
like here this is this is the point i
mean you know a high precision model is
the model that's living in this bottom
left and a high recall model is one
that's living in the top right
okay thank you
hi thanks for the talk um
the slopes
or the utility
you said if you have a dynamic pricing
that you could implement how does it
affect the slopes would they curve yeah
i haven't really thought through that
math so no okay i'm not i'm not 100 sure
i've thought through it a little bit
more if you're saying you know you're
going to have two points and then you
know human review in the middle yeah but
in principle you can do it i mean i
don't think it's like okay maybe it
starts getting a little more complex
but i think you know i don't think it
changes the principle of the yeah the
principle
the slopes should curve i i i agree i
think they probably would end up curving
this really appeals to my economics
background but one thing i wasn't sure
about are you using these utility curves
as like an example of how to build a
mental model or would you really
generate indifference curves and
optimize your models against them in
cross-validation in in many cases so we
i have literally done this now
it often ends up being that when you're
thinking about different models and what
you're doing here is you're trying to
say i have a model i need to set a
threshold where should my threshold be
and when you're doing that this might
not be the best graph to be producing
you know i think this graph is good for
building your your sort of mental model
but in the end you could just plot a
graph of like what is my utility versus
my threshold i want the high one right
so
you know i think there are better ways
of framing it at that point i think this
is a good way of sort of building up
that mental model of like hey what am i
really trying to do here especially as
it comes to the fact that like you're
not necessarily going to get it exactly
right particularly like what is the
prevalence because your training data
and then at inference time is different
so the world may have changed so you
know the economy changes suddenly you
know i wager for a lot of loan giving
organizations right now that prevalence
is lower now than it was a year ago
so you don't necessarily have full full
knowledge
thank you
thank you
um got a couple more minutes any more
questions
um
i'll head over here let's include this
side of the room let's do it
thank you um so you talked about um
data scientists learning the language of
business to be able to communicate with
business as opposed to business learning
the language of data science although
you sort of said that's possible
but then they get all the praise and we
don't want that do you think there's
value in sort of meeting halfway where
we learn each other's languages and that
leads to
defining better metrics for the business
more better sort of more precise utility
um and if yes then how do you achieve
that in the organization uh yeah that's
a really good question so i think um
it probably really starts depending on
the ways in which you're doing models
and how how closely they are to like the
business outcomes and so if you're you
know in a large organization and you're
building a model that's going to be used
across many different entities in some
way it starts getting a lot harder to
think about like the you know the bottom
line of this particular model this
particular modeling decision because
it's it's shared across different use
cases um so in those cases i think you
know okay maybe these like f1 scores or
other sorts of measures might be you
know as close a proxy as you can come up
with
um
i think that
regardless of the language being used
one of the things that i i've seen is
that
when you're doing the data science work
when we're actually trying to make
decisions about which model is is better
having the outcome that really matters
for the business is really important and
so
you know as kind of a little fast and
lose in terms of how these language
works but but generally speaking when
you're having those meetings even if
it's you know collaboration with the
product manager it needs to have the
sense of like what are we really trying
to accomplish as a business and so
it's great if product managers also can
really be in the weeds and sort of
saying like okay i see where this is
hard trying to optimize this especially
if we're in these cases with like
feedback loops and things like this and
so we're going to say hey look like
we're just going to use this kind of
measure as a proxy because we think this
is the you know the best way just to
deliver an mvp and then we'll iterate
from there so that's a little tricky one
to get get it exactly right
but i think as data scientists you know
in terms of getting people part way
there if we do a little bit of the work
to talk to business i think that also
builds up credibility if then you want
to say hey look this is no longer the
easiest way to think about it like we
need to move into a different direction
thank you very much
thank you
dylan and
i think we need to swap over the next
speakers so if everyone could
show their appreciation